be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so while I continue to write the script
for Superman red Sun and what I wanted
to do here is have a discussion about
Hank pens most infamous act hitting his
wife the reason for this is that I think
it's important for us not to turn away
from stories like this and DC's identity
crisis these stories help to define the
comic-book industry and in a lot of ways
establish the status quo on how far the
limits could be pushed before fans and
creators reached a line of demarcation
between what's tasteful and what's not
so while being someone that never had an
ongoing solo series a hank Pam is one of
Marvel's oldest characters dating back
to his first appearance and tales to
astonish issue number 27 having been
created by the combined efforts of
Marvel's top creators during the Silver
Age Stan Lee Steve Ditko Jack Kirby and
Larry Lieber while his initial
appearance in January of 1962 only gave
us his non-superpowered form September
of the same year introduced us to the
ant-man character a superhero who was
capable of shrinking down to the size of
an ant while not the most impressive of
abilities the Hank Pym was also given us
as a technological genius in order to
offset his rather mundane powers as the
founder of the Avengers and the creator
of Ultron as well as the infinite
Avengers mansion the Hank Pam's
contributions to the Marvel Universe
have seen both sides of the argument
ranging from outright disgust with
Ultron to one reception with the
infinite Avengers mansion's universe
wide teleportation capabilities and so
the question becomes why while Marvel
has written their fair share of
controversial stories dealing with
sexism racism in overall prejudice by
various characters and teams
why would marvel write a story involving
one of their characters as part of one
of the premiere teams hitting his wife
the answer to this question comes
directly from the creator of the story
Jim shooter himself in a blog post on
the subject of Hank Pym and his wife
Janet Van Dyne the Jim shooter states
that when he took over the Avengers
title in 1976 with issue number 151 the
element of Hank Pym was largely a
laughable concept more often than not
Hank Pym was always the first member of
the Avengers team to be captured or
defeated and that because they had
shifted him around so often fans had no
real love for the character with Ultron
being his only real achievement in his
publication history the inner turmoil of
Hank Pym was compounded by the fact that
Janet Van Dyne was wealthy and
successful in by extension the opposite
of Hank Pym himself in an effort to
restore fan confidence Jim shooter began
focusing heavily on stories relating to
the marriage between the two and
with Avengers issues number 212 to 213
presented the infamous moment in a story
or Hank Pym became increasingly violent
resulting in Captain America kicking him
off the Avengers team until such a time
as a decision can be made about what to
do with them
I
so the story initially picks up with ham
pens returned to the Avengers following
his brainwashing at the hands of Ultron
while Hank Pym is getting prepared for
his first meeting back with the Avengers
he demonstrates a frustration with Janet
Van Dyne inability to choose her costume
while Janet Van Dyne surprised at Hank
M's demeanor gives her pause for concern
she gives it a casual dismissal I guess
and eventually joins him as the two of
them set off to the meeting at Avengers
mansion or from here we pick up with
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne in their
meeting with Captain America Iron Man
Thor and the newly inducted tira when
the statement is made by Thor and Iron
Man that the elections for a new
chairman should be waived and Captain
America should remain as head of the
team Hank Pym lashes out again revealing
that he resents the fact that no one
consulted him on this decision the
furthermore Janet Van Dyne states that
with haip hems current attitude she
feels as though he is mentally moving
further and further away from her now as
the story continues Hank Pym
demonstrates a continued attitude of
irritation of frustration in various
forms but generally chooses his wife as
the person he lashes out at in one
instance Janet Van Dyne makes an offhand
remark in response to Hank Pym
irritation about one of his devices not
working what she says is that she can
contact their Butler who can bring
another one of their devices to the
Avengers mansion
so that Hank Pym doesn't have to repair
the existing one in response to this I
hate him accuses her of enjoying the
idea of flaunt her money about and front
of people and that not only does he not
need her money that he also doesn't need
her which sends a saddened Janet Van
Dyne into a temporary state of shock
while Captain America and Thor express a
concern the group ultimately decides to
ignore the outburst and continue with
their mission to Washington DC now
eventually the attitude of Hank Pym as
well as his outbursts come to a head
when the Avengers encounter a possible
villain while Captain America is able to
talk her down from her potential assault
Hank Pym shoots her in the back with one
of his energy devices while Captain
America is able to neutralize the
situation before it becomes a
conflict this brings a behavior of Hank
Pym to a point that the Avengers can no
longer ignore in calling Hank Pam into
an informal hearing Captain America
states that Hank Pam's recent behavior
towards both his wife as well as various
others indicates that he is not of sound
mind or at the very least operating in
the authoritative capacity that comes
with being an Avenger temporarily
dismissing Hank Pym from the group
Captain America states that the
dismissal will be followed by a
court-martial at which point Hank Pym
will stand for his actions now in an
effort to regain his standing with the
Avengers the Hank Pym returns to his
roots building a robot named salvation
one which he designs to attack the
Avengers and with the intention of
saving them at a crucial moment Hank Pym
believes that this will restore the
team's faith in him after walking in on
his operation and catching him by
surprise
Janet pleads with Hank him to stop his
insanity at which point he strikes her
across the face knocking her to the
ground
demanding the Janis stay quiet about his
plan the two of them set off for Hank
PEM's court-martial now once they arrive
Captain America states that the wall of
the Avengers is to be just as much a
humanitarian group as a combat group
while Hank hems action of attacking the
villain could be understandable under
certain circumstances his act of
attacking someone from behind combined
with his recent behavior makes him more
of a liability to the team and an asset
in response a Hank Pym makes his
argument in claiming that Captain
America isn't siding against him based
on the merit of his actions but because
Captain America himself is in love with
the villain sensing a chance to create a
romantic relationship with her
Captain America viewed Hank Pym as
someone who looked to get in the way is
stating that he was a true hero in the
battle The Avengers come to the
conclusion that Hank Pym is beyond
reason however the nail and the coffin
comes when Janet Van Dyne removes her
sunglasses revealing a black eye and
pleads a final time with Hank Pym to
cease his madness
seeing no other choice Hank Pym
activates salvation 1 which promptly
attacks the Avengers with Janet Van Dyne
revealing that the robot was designed by
Hank Pym the Avengers Assemble and to
feed the contraption but realizing that
all hope is lost
hank pym admits defeat and resigns his
position from the Avengers team
so following this story the legacy of
Hank Pym followed that he was famous for
two things
building Ultron and hitting his wife fan
reaction to the story was exactly what
you would think you would be and that
people were absolutely livid and various
letters to the editors fans expressed a
severe distaste to the story while most
individuals were accepting of Marvel
walking a line between acceptable and
unacceptable in terms of societal
standards on appropriate content many
found the event to be outright
distasteful but furthermore due to the
fact that the story garnered so much
attention and with Jim shooter boosting
sales for the Avengers while writing the
series Marvel chose not to shy away from
the negative criticism and instead chose
to embrace it
while the domestic abuse issues between
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne drove a
wedge that couldn't be repaired which
led to their divorce Marvel kept the
theme of Hank Pym hitting his wife as an
ongoing gag with characters dismissing
him using an offhand remark referencing
the incident while I have not been able
to find any evidence indicating that Jim
shooter addressed the topic during his
time as writer or editor in chief at
Marvel in the same blog post as was
referenced above he tells us that the
way the story was initially written Hank
Pym was supposed to throw his hands up
in exasperation accidentally striking
Janet Van Dyne but when the story was
given to artist Bob Hall he opted to
draw the scenario as it was presented
rather than how it was written the
result is that while Hank Pym eventually
returned to the Avengers in an
on-again-off-again position his story as
a wife beater and creator of Ultron cast
a shadow over him one that never really
seemed to go away with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will catch you guys later peace